hello
so my name is alexander hauser i'm an
assistant professor from the department
of drug design and pharmacology
at the university of copenhagen in
denmark and today i would like to talk
about how i'm exploiting data-driven
approaches to facilitate
gpcr pharmacology and drug discovery in
the context of pharmacogenomics and
personalized medicine
and specifically specifically i start
with a little introduction on biomedical
data how i'm using data to rationalize
research questions and then i'm going to
present some of my recent projects
linking computational and
pharmacological data on some specific
examples
so as you know there's been an explosion
of data in recent years
virtually all domains of the bio medical
sciences from the number of
published literature articles to
generally databases and resources
genomic data genetic variation gene
expression protein interactions and
protein structures compound libraries
and whole pathways not just in human but
a range of model organisms
and we have
now access to data at many different
scales and resolutions
the nih european
and european bioinformatics institute
estimated that there is now more than
200 petabytes of processed biological
data data
similarly you might have seen these
charts which show how the reduction in
sequencing cost has resulted in an
explosion of
of data with now many hundreds hundreds
of thousands of individuals
having been whole exome or even whole
genome sequence
and as you also see here on the side
that the main driver of the cost is not
the sequencing anymore but rather the
sample collection and the downstream
analysis
which i expect to continue to become
more and more of a bottleneck
so hence we need to transition into
putting the tools into people's hands
and to analyze and make use of the data
they are they are generating
and given the wealth of information we
need to we also need to think in how we
can best apply informatics and data
science approaches on the integration of
these diverse data sets to gain new
knowledge with the with the emphasize on
the
on the understanding of human health and
biology
and doing so
we need um new approaches and the
targeted combination in the selected
biological system
to advance in the pharmaceutical
sciences and drug discovery
so here i would like to present a
project on gpcr pharmacogenomics and
specifically how we can elucidate the
spectrum and impact of how a gpcr
variant influences ligand binding
signaling and an ultimately therapeutic
effect
of physiology
and this is important because
despite rigorous clinical testing
of medical products do we still reside
in times of imprecision medicine
exemplified by how few people benefit
from
our most prescribed drugs
so that in the future
we hope to tailor selection and dosage
of drugs to the individual's composition
what you see here is
adverse reactions um
actually do uh make up somewhere between
the fourth and sixth leading cause of
mortality
and
90 to 99 of the population has at least
one high risk variant for a recognized
pharmacogenomic gene
and today there is variations in 20
genes that affect now i think more than
100 medications that are actionable in
in the clinic
so what you see here what contributes to
the impressive precision medicine
is
uh to the largest extent the individual
characteristics of an individual such as
such as age and gender but also the
pathological conditions comorbidities
polypharmacy
environmental exposure and lifestyle
factors such as smoking
and uh and sleep
and um
and of course and what that's what i'm
going to focus on here today is that the
genetic contribution to precision
medicine has been estimated to range
somewhere between 20 to 30 percent
where we can distinguish the genetic
factors into variation in acne genes
and into variations in drug targets
and in recent years there's been quite
an increase in both pharmacogenetic and
pharmacogenomics given given new tools
such as targeted gene sequencing and the
advent of
the human genome project but also
the advent of larger consortia such as
the pharmdkb
1000 genomes project
and and many others whereas if you look
at the
trajectories of the tpcr there's also
been some some
milestones and important breakthroughs
in the in the complex studying of gpc
signaling but also
given the the breakthroughs in cryo
electron microscopy giving us insights
into the receptor g protein interaction
and the different folds
of of the gpcr
so among the genetic factors that can
impact drug response we can distinguish
between
variation altering the thermokinetic
chemical kinetics such as the absorption
distribution
metabolism and execution of drugs and
on the other side the pharmacodynamics
the effects of the drugs made mediated
by the drug targets
such as nuclear receptors iron channels
kinases and ngpcr
and here i'm talking about and focusing
on on gpcr specifically and this is
because
um gpcrs regulate virtually every aspect
of human physiology
and
yeah they're organizing complex uh
activities uh and communication between
different tissues given a broad range of
hormones and as you see here
um from from mood behavior to smell
vision and taste tbc are involved in
nearly every physiological
component so it's not a surprise that
dpcr make up more than a third of all
molecular targets
of a proof drug
so given that gps are attractive drug
targets we investigated the following
questions in in our study which i i
start here with
um so first how how variable are these
gpc drug targets in the human population
second are
individuals with variant receptors
likely to respond differently to drugs
and third what is the estimated economic
burden associated with variation in gpc
drug targets and the answers to these
questions have important implications
for personalized medicine
um yeah that that considers an
individual's genetic markup makeup
in in designing treatment strategies
so as you as you know we are all
different and so are our genomes as a
result of very subtle differences in in
our dna and it is estimated that
on average
between two individuals is roughly point
six percent difference in base pairs
from our whole genome
however there is only about two percent
of the genome which actually encodes for
for the roughly 20 000 genes and
proteins
which we refer to as the exon
and the mutations in the in the exome
are expected to have most profound
impact on physiology and this is what we
have been focusing here
but we can actually distinguish
different types of mutations such as
synonymous
where there's no change in the amino
acid composition mismutations which lead
to a residue change in protein structure
and loss of function mutations such as
frame shift or intermutations which have
a much larger impact on protein
structure
um
so here we we focus on omissions
mutations that have a change literally
changed amino acid composition and also
we glimpsed a little bit into loss of
function mutation
so in order to assess
the the prevalence the functional and
economic impact due to gpc attract
target variation and variable drug
response we employed a wide range of of
data types and data resources starting
from from all drugs
all approved drugs targeting targeting
gpcrs then the variant data from at the
time 60 000 individuals but also denoble
mutations from father mother child trios
as well as genotypes from the 1000
genomes project and on the other hand
functional effect data on ligand binding
g-protein arrested interface the
posterization modifications
known variant disease associations but
also clinical annotations of drug
variant pairs
and then we have also include sales data
from the national health
system in the in the uk
where we had information about
prescription and sales data of drugs
targeting gpcrs
so starting with the first question what
is the prevalence of gpc drug targets to
have a missing variation within an
individual
we
employed a drug target data
as well as genotype information for two
hundred five two thousand five hundred
individuals that allowed us to
characterize the mutational landscape of
gps drug targets within an individual
and here we show that an individual
harbors
nearly 70 missing mutations and probably
even more given given broader data sets
in their gbc drug targets and among
those an average of eight variants per
individual have previously known
clinical associations with altered drug
response
then
we next seeked out to investigate what
fraction of the variant that are likely
to have an impact given their location
so here we've used aggregated data from
the exact consortium as well as all
protein structures that have been
available at the time
obtaining data from the gpcrdb
integrating these to identify functional
sites and infer the prevalence of
mutations within known functional sites
and for this it is important to to know
and do
to appreciate that
mutations can have an impact on various
levels such as on the receptor integrity
such as on the cell surface expression
stability
maybe also the trafficking and
localization
and then the more sort of classical
intuitive impact like on ligand ligand
binding on the potency maybe on the
selectivity of the kinetics
but also the signaling the function of
selectivity bisignaling is very
important the constitutive activity
activation kinetics
and the internalization rates but also
on the interaction and interface to um
homo and and heteromass or
membrane interactions and there's of
course different different methods in
essays to approach each of them
specifically
so here given our broader
functional characterization in overview
we identified that there is there are
mutations that that have an impact on
different different regions and we
showed that
15 of all variants are actually located
in known functional sites such as the
ligand binding site
effector binding site post translation
and modification sites and and
microswitches
and and each of those have a different
impact on
on protein protein function
so we then focused on the new opiate
receptor which is a highly variable dpcr
drug target and the primary mediator of
many of our opioid energetics and which
gives rise to the current opioid
epidemic
so surprisingly we identified
a variant that have no evident effect on
the wild type response which you see
here in endomorph and drop an endomorph
in one
but have a significant effect upon drug
exposure such as a reduced response such
as for morphine or even
or no response for couprinophen or even
the gain of function for as in this case
for naloxone which is not evident from
its response to the natural ligand
and uh especially in the case of
naloxone this is a
detoxifying agent in patients with
opioid overdose that's actually quite
detrimental so if you if you were to
identify these individuals
carriers of these mutations then you
want to be
informed about that
based on that we further developed an
economic model based on drug sales from
the nhs in the uk and and then estimated
the the possible economic impact of drug
target variability which
given different
caveats we estimated to be somewhere
between 14 and 500 million which pounds
annually
and and these estimates are likely only
the the tip of the ice that given the
expenses
and the extensive use of these drugs
across across the globe
so
taken together we showed that there's
extensive genetic variation in drug
targeted receptors with potential
implications for drug binding receptor
activation and signaling
and that genetic variants may lead to
unintended consequences
if and when treated with the drug and
that the understanding and incorporating
an incorporation of the effects of
polymer polymorphisms has the potential
to to curtail
the recurrent unaccounted expenditure on
public health
so the next question is then how do we
translate the genetics informed in vitro
findings into into the clinics
and looking at all curated
pharmacogenomics associations curated by
the farm dkb which is a comprehensive
resource
that
creates knowledge about the impact of
genetic variation on drug response
we've seen various gps targeting drugs
which have drug labels from from fda or
the email or other medical agencies
that are at least informative if not
actionable or required
but actually there's no gpcr target
variant labeled which lead to drug
labels so
if we look at the variant labels so
looking at the pharmacodynamic so the
the reason why the the db set
gpcr drugs here on the left hand side
are
part of drug labels is all due to the
pharmacokinetics
whereas the on the thermal dynamics the
specific there's no specific gpcr
variant that is currently labeled as
being
actionable or required
in in any of the medical agencies
however there are
a number of variants where we know they
have
either in vitro or also in vivo
implications for drug response
so the question is then why are there
so few variants in the first place that
have associations to alter drug response
but also
uh why are so few actually actionable in
the clinic and i think one explanation
is that many variants are very rare
and or have not been tested or exposed
to to medical treatment by their
carriers
and this is because
we have not had the access to
combine genotype with phenotype data at
scale as we have now
so that's what you see here um
where you see
here the the beautiful trajectory from
the discovery of the dna double helix to
the first fully sequenced genomes to a
catalog human variation to integrated
health biobanks
which hold a treasure trove of
information so that now previously we've
been really scaling up on the
on the on the number of
genomes we've been sequencing but now
more importantly we can also integrate
that
with um with a healthcare record
and phenotype data and
um
here i i gonna give in the second part
of my presentation i'm going to give a
little
insight into how we make use of biobank
data such as the uk biobank
which consists of more than 500 000
participants that have been genotyped
and and
phenotyped on on various clinical
measures
so in this example here we we
investigated the human glucagon receptor
which is involved in maintaining blood
glucose homeostasis
we performed molecular pharmacological
phenotyping of
38 missing variants
so those that are changing the amino
acid composition of the of the receptor
and specifically those we selected that
are located in the receptor
extracellular domain at the google gone
interface here which you see here in in
red the red peptide
and these variants were then
characterized in in terms of
cnp accumulation to assess g alpha s
ethnically
and recruitment to beta arrest in one
two
and lastly we investigated how the cnp
impairing variant and wild type-like
variant
differentially impacted carriers
of the uk biobank
so
on the left you see um we identify so
that that's
with the heat map of all the 38
missing variants and on the top half
where it says on the right alterations
in three two and one pathway these have
had significant impact
in
at least one of the measured endpoints
so you see here the the potency the the
efficacy variant of the curve as as
three sort of endpoints
and here we we
you see that we identified eight
variants with decreased gs signaling
and then also performed binding
experience experiments which revealed
that the preserved glucagon which
preserved which
revealed preserved glucagon affinity
although with a significantly reduced
binding capacity
and at the bottom where it says white
type like you see that we have
identified a large number of mutations
that had no apparent effect
on gs signaling or arrested recruitment
at least not on our cell types and uh
and essays and uh just want to remember
that um and remind you that there is
there is uh good evidence for instance
for the melanoma cotton receptor which
has shown that um you may not capture
in for instance the cmp accumulation
essay all the extend a variant can can
impact
receptor function as i indicated also
before
so we then
ask the question how do the variants
that are impacting cellular phenotypes
affect individuals at the clinical
or physiological level
and in order to to study this we
identified all carriers
of these 38 tested variants in the
glucagon receptor based on the quality
controls sub-cohort of the uk biobank
so here you see we started with 200 000
exon sequence individual worlds which we
have
a quality control for relatedness
ancestry um genotyping quality and and
consent
which we were then left with which uh
with
154-ish thousands
in individuals and among those we
identified roughly a thousand carriers
um
of
one or many of these genetic variants
on which we then performed a whole
genome regression burden testing
and and in doing so by grouping the
cnp affecting variants and contrasting
them to the wild type like variants we
observe that the group of the cnp
affecting
mutations had a higher
rate of severe obesity as well as bmi
and body fat percentage
while the pharmacologically while
top-like mutations were not associated
with increased
cardio metabolic outcomes
and
these observations are also online with
the with the role
of the glucagon system in metabolism
and also support gs as the main
signaling pathway affecting the
physiological roles of the glucagon
receptor
but also
that in v2 data is indicative for real
world
outcomes
um and can be directly linked with
with healthcare data
i also want to advertise here a little
bit
a resource
that
is a one-stop shop for gpcr so maybe
some of you may have heard
called the gbcrdb
where
a part of it is also a resource for
genetic variants for pharmacogenomics
research towards the goals of advancing
this field and to fuel
pharmacogenomic research
with yet to be a characterized variant
for instance
so please have a look here and you also
see that we have expanded recently also
into
g proteins and arrestin as their own
database with their own tools and
own merits
and um
with this i think i i would like to uh
leave you with some
some concluding remarks remarks
that uh gpgrs are still relevant drug
targets but are also a treasure trove
for
unappreciated human physiology and as an
opinion opportunity for
personalized medicine
and that we can obtain new insights on
biochemical principles and mechanistic
insights from from existing
biomedical data that we integrate
from genetics pharmacology all the way
to to healthcare data that can
lead to new knowledge
and potentially lead to fine-tuned
fine-tuned clinical practice practices
but also that
there's a huge knowledge
discrepancy between gpcr
and an untapped potential across many
disease areas
with many gpcr still clinically
unexploited
so
what you see here is the the
discrepancy between for instance
citations but also available
availability of
of two compounds
patterns and and also protein structures
um
so
when we talk about dpcr
as drug targets we we usually talk about
small fraction of gpcr but there's still
many many gpcrs that are both offering
but also none of them that can still be
exploited
for drug discovery
and
then last but not least i would like to
thank all my supporters funding agencies
and colleagues who have contributed to
this work
especially my
my
past and current supervisors david
gloriam hence bryan osborne
madan babu
as well as mata rosenkilde from the
glucon receptor study
and i would like to thank you for your
attention and please feel free to reach
out by email or twitter in case you have
any any ideas for collaborations or any
any questions regarding my presentation
thank you very much